dank steinhäuser ja ist es schlussspurt
vor der sommerpause oder vielleicht
sollte man sagen ein letzter kraftakt
vor den parlamentarischen ferien in
diesem jahr der ob es tatsächlich so
viele ferien werden oder so viel
entspannte zeit das kann man im moment
ja noch gar nicht absehen heute und
morgen jedenfalls hat der deutsche
bundestag noch so ziemlich nochmal so
ziemlich alles auf der agenda was in
deutschland in europa und in der welt
gerade wichtig ist oder auch gewesen ist
ein paar stichworte habe ich mitgebracht
schutz vor wind 19 wird diskutiert
konsequenzen aus der flutkatastrophe im
aatal vor einem jahr das
beschaffungswesen der bundeswehr der
nato beitritt von finnland und schweden
die und der untersuchungsausschuss und
die enquete-kommission zum
afghanistan-einsatz der bundeswehr es
geht um das chaos an den flughäfen und
schon gestern um das thema
energiesicherheit und gleich heute um 9
geht es um das thema erneuerbare
energien und die sind ja in mehrerer
hinsicht wichtig auf der einen seite was
die energieversorgung bei uns angeht und
auf der anderen seite ein viel
weitreichenderes problem noch mal
zusätzlich die erhitzung und die
konsequenzen daraus vier gesetzentwürfe
stehen gleich um 9 auf der tagesordnung
drei anträge gibt es dazu und zwei gäste
haben wir zu diesem thema die sich schon
länger mit dem thema beschäftigen nicht
erst seit dieser legislaturperiode ist
unser traum hat seit ich freue mich dass
wir uns sind ingrid nestle die
sprecherin für klimaschutz und energie
der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und
andreas jung ist bei uns ja dieselbe
funktion hat in der unionsfraktion ihnen
beiden schönen guten morgen schön dass
sie da sind fangen wir mal mit dem
eingemachten an frauen ist wie teuer
wird energie wenn man von der aktuellen
entwicklung ausgeht im herbst seien
also schon jetzt kaufen die unternehmen
gas zum sechsfachen preis von dem was
sie früher eingekauft haben das heißt
also alte verträge ja und was sie jetzt
am weltmarkt nach beschaffen müssen wenn
die eigenen verträge auslaufen oder
nicht mehr bedient werden von russland
bezahlen sie das sechsfache tendenz geht
sogar weiter nach oben das ist im herbst
noch nicht bei den endkunden angekommen
ja das kommt erst langsam zeit versetzt
so bis nächsten sommer vielleicht sogar
noch ein bisschen länger bei den
endkunden an aber man kann sich
vorstellen dass die preissteigerungen
dramatisch sind dh der jungen heizen
warmes wasser luxusgut
klar ist es droht wirklich eine notlage
die regierung hat ja die alarmstufe
ausgerufen alarm schlägt dann muss man
auch entsprechend handeln und deshalb
sind wir der meinung das ist alles in
den topf muss um so eine mami lage
abzuwenden da wird manches gemacht aber
zu wenig es wird zu wenig gemacht bei
einsparung in öffentlichen gebäuden zu
wenig anreize bei privaten bei der
wirtschaft und deshalb wir wissen nicht
was kommt müssen uns darauf vorbereiten
dass eine notlage droht und deshalb ist
alles machen wir gleich alles ein klein
bisschen auseinander von auseinander vor
nässe trotzdem sind im moment keine
weiteren entlassungen geplant hören wir
aus der bundesregierung haben wir auch
aus der ampel-koalition warum müssen
wenn man doch weiß wie sie es gerade
auch geschildert haben dass auch die
kosten definitiv steigen werden ja herr
scholz hat ja mit dem begriff der
konzertierten aktion letztlich die
nächste debatte schon ausgelöst und ja
wir haben noch kein paket wieder fertig
ja aber die diskussionen darüber wie vor
allem diejenigen die besonders getroffen
werden von diesem preis steigung wie die
entlastet werden können die läuft schon
längst wieder wir müssen aber auch so
ehrlich sein zu sagen diese
preissteigerungen können wir nicht
einfach dauerhaften steuergeld abfangen
ja wir haben jetzt schon über 30
milliarden ausgegeben und die
preissteigerung die wir bisher gesehen
haben waren eigentlich ein laues
lüftchen im vergleich zu dem sturm der
noch kommt das heißt wir müssen
tatsächlich hätte ich mein kollege jung
ist auch gesagt hat wir müssen weniger
verbrauchen wenn wir weniger verbrauchen
werden die preise für alle günstiger da
war das letzte lng tanker schiff dass
man noch ordert ist immer das teuerste
und setzt den preis verlangen ich war
ein bisschen überrascht muss sie gerade
sagen herr jungen dass sie das thema
sparen sehr früh auch schon gemeint
haben hier in diesem gespräch ansonsten
fällt mir das ehrlich gesagt wenn man
die sprecherinnen sprecher der
unions-fraktion hört nicht ganz so
dollar auf also dass ich hatte immer so
den eindruck gegeben sie eher mit
spitzen fingern dran jetzt haben sie es
relativ prominente etwas was wollen sie
denn konkret ran und was wollen sie den
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern vor
allem auch mit geben also eindruck
täuscht wir fordern seit langem ein gas
sparplan eine hier gibt es eine
konzertierte aktion mit
gesellschaftlichen gruppen was wir
brauchen ist es die zusammenkommen die
entscheiden können nämlich der bund die
länder kommunale spitzenverbände und als
erstes auf den weg bringen ein
einsparprogramm für öffentliche
einrichtungen es gibt es in italien seit
dem ersten mai seit dem ersten mai in
allen öffentlichen einrichtungen
gebäuden in italien darf nur gekürt
werden auf 27 grad runter in deutschland
gibt es im bundeswirtschaftsministerium
nicht mehr in der gesamten
bundesregierung geschweige denn in allen
öffentlichen gebäuden von italien lernen
heißt hier sparen lernen dass unsere
erwartung an olaf scholz an robert
habeck nicht nur reden zum hier jetzt
konkret handeln bei den privaten haben
wir einen vorschlag gemacht anreize zu
geben der präsident der
bundesnetzagentur klaus müller sagt
durch heizungsoptimierung wenn man jetzt
die heizung gezielt optimal einstellt
kann man zehn bis 15 prozent sparen wird
aber noch nicht massenhaft gemacht da
wollen wir mit einem gutschein anreiz zu
geben und die regierung selbst hat
angekündigt freiwillige auktionierung im
bereich der wirtschaft auch drei monate
nach beginn dieser zuspitzung der krise
plätze bei ankündigung wir meinen das
muss jetzt konkret werden das muss jetzt
gemacht werden und nicht erst im herbst
wenn die mangel lage da ist ist dafür zu
spät frau henzler gerne direkt dazu ja
also ich freue mich sehr dass die union
jetzt dieses thema effizienz und
einsparen auch so in den mittelpunkt
stellt war tatsächlich ist das ein ganz
großer brocken also neben all dem elend
ordern ja wo sich minister habe ich
schon darum gekümmert hat und wir schon
viele gesetze auf den weg gebracht haben
neben dem bereich erneuerbare energien
hoch fahren wo wir gleich im plenum das
größte erneuerbaren energien programm
aller zeiten verabschieden werden hoffe
ich zumindest sehr ist dieser bereich
effizienz einsparen damit kann man
richtig viel hinbekommen 10 15 20
prozent sagen die unterschiedlichen
studien und deswegen jahr arbeiten wir
intensiv an dem thema deswegen ja ist
minister haarweg sicherlich der der am
entschiedensten handelt in der
bundesregierung deswegen hat er mit ganz
vielen akteuren schon einen großen plan
ja und einen großen appell und eine ganz
klare ansage gemacht wir müssen alle
sparen es ist halt nicht so einfach das
mit ordnungsrecht zu machen weil es
unheimlich kleinteich ist wir müssen an
ganz vielen kleinen stellen sparen das
will keiner ordnungsrechtlich
kontrollieren außer vielleicht beim
heizpilze und deswegen müssen wir da
auch kommunizieren und ehrlich gesagt
ich habe die union da noch nicht so
unterstützend wahrgenommen in der
breiten öffentlichkeit dann darf ich das
jetzt noch mal machen wir unterstützen
das ausdrücklich wir haben gefordert
dass der bundestag vor an geht die
präsidentin greift es auf tut es wir
wollen dass die bundesregierung die
bundesligen schafften länder des rathaus
vor ort und schloss bellevue gemeinsam
das signal geben wir sparen bier gehen
voran dadurch kommt dass in den topf
entlastet wirtschaft und wohnen und es
ist auch ein signal die lage ist
wirklich ernst und deshalb müssen wir
jetzt tun was wir jetzt tun können um
uns auf den winter vorzubereiten
frage von es ist nicht ein bisschen auch
was wahres dran was der jungen sagt wenn
er sagt irgendwie wirtschaftsminister
tut zu weniger als eigentlich nötig wäre
wenn wir jetzt beispielsweise angucken
was die gasversorger angeht wie war
anfang der woche ja in der diskussion
wie man mit denen umgeht daher ist es
wir müssen die instrumente nachschärfen
aber man will sie noch nicht einsetzen
deswegen ist ja die frage was kommt
werden diese angeschlagenen unternehmen
werden die unterstützt oder läuft es
darauf hinaus dass die höheren preise
umgelegt werden auf im grunde alle also
ich habe noch nie einen minister erlebt
der so entschlossen handelt und sich so
der wirklichkeit stellt vier minister
habe deshalb sich nicht ist nicht so war
dass wir zu wenig tut er tut sehr sehr
viel die frage wie dieser stelle mal
unterlegen genau wie man die situation
umgeht also da geht es ja im wesentlich
nicht glaubt man kann es so ansprechen
der zeitung das unternehmen juniper die
zahlen liegen seit letzten mittwoch also
jetzt nicht gestern seit einer woche auf
dem tisch wir haben über das wochenende
in den instrumentenkasten geschaffen ja
den wir brauchen um der situation
umzugehen und die entscheidung welches
instrument genau zum einsatz kommt da
muss man schon noch ein paar tage länger
einmal auf die sein wo auch eine kluge
entscheidung und nicht nur eine schnelle
entscheidung zu treffen sind viel zu
ungeduldig sind sie zu oben geduldet na
ja wir haben als das energie sicherungs
gesetz gemacht wurde darauf hingewiesen
dass dieser paragraf 24 der preis
anpassungsmechanismus nicht die antwort
ist der verschiebt das problem aber der
löst nicht das problem das war der grund
warum bei andere dinge im energie
sicherungs gesetz hätten wir mit
getragen warum wir nicht zugestimmt
haben diese erkenntnis hat jetzt auch
die koalition wirklich nicht kritisieren
dass eine dynamische lage wo man auch
kurzfristig reagieren muss was wir nicht
verstehen ist dass jetzt ein bauchladen
gemacht wird unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten direkter staatlicher
eingriffsmöglichkeiten einerseits einer
umlage andererseits und des verschiebens
gestiegener preise auf alle endkunden
da wird es die regierung breit
ermächtigt wir meinen dass wir im
parlament schon wesentliche
entscheidungen treffen müssen und dass
deshalb eine parlamentarische
entscheidung ist wenn man so oder so
vorgeht bei aller flexibilität wie
möglich essen vielleicht mal nachgefragt
weil er gar nicht ohne bauchladen weil
man ja einfach ganz viele verschiedene
instrumente jetzt also machen muss ja
oder anwenden muss ist schon richtig
dass man sind jetzt drei dinge im raum
das erste ist die möglichkeit der
regierung stützend einzugreifen so wie
in der finanzkrise sowie in der korona
krise dass diese möglichkeit geschaffen
wird erstmal ist richtig dass dann eben
weil man nicht weiß wie die situation
ist kommt man damit weiter auch eine
zweite möglichkeit geschaffen wird
nämlich gestiegene preise umzulegen oder
weiterzugeben ist nachvollziehbar aber
die regierung selbst sagt es kann nur
das eine oder das andere gemacht werden
so sagen es auch die ampel fraktionen
dann meinen wir muss man sich aber auch
für das eine und das andere entscheiden
das wird es mit diesem gesetz nicht
gemacht und deshalb bleiben da fragen
wir könnten an dieser stelle jetzt
wahrscheinlich locker zehn minuten reden
über das einst meiner lieblingsworte
übrigen zement aus der vergangenen
wochen kraftwerke bereitstellungs gesetz
also die frage mit welcher energie wenn
man erstmal überbrücken irgendwie die
lücken wie jetzt wer tatsächlich
entstehen das überspringen wir jetzt
aber mal weil wir den debatten verlaufen
bisschen vorhersagen kann und gucken auf
das was sich um 9 uhr diskutiert wird
nämlich insgesamt sind glaube ich 20
gesetze und verordnungen rund um die
erneuerbaren energien im moment
überarbeitet worden sind ein weg aus der
energiekrise unabhängig werden von kohle
gas und
massive ausbau der neuen energien und
jetzt ein neues ziel 80 prozent bis 2030
oder wenn man es mal anders rechnet
verdoppelung ökostrom im vergleich zu 21
und das innerhalb der nächsten jahre
verstehen sie die lieder ein bisschen
skeptisch sind also ich verstehe
diejenigen die sagen wow das ist schnell
ja das ist schnell und hat er sich
gefragt sehr schnell sehr gut andere
sagen dann ich glaube einfach nicht dran
ja aber die lage ist ernst gerade eben
haben sie mich noch gefragt kann wenn
sie nicht zu langsam und zögerlich ja
wir brauchen diese geschwindigkeit und
sie sind eine riesen herausforderung und
wir haben sie angenommen natürlich kann
jetzt keiner vorhersagen ob das ganz
genauso gelingt und natürlich kann das
auch nicht minister habeck und wir im
parlament alleine entscheiden natürlich
brauchen wir genehmigungsbehörden vor
ort länder kommunen ja die mitziehen
leute die die projekte machen natürlich
ist das ein gemeinschaftsprojekt aber es
steht unheimlich viel auf dem spiel für
unsere gesellschaft und deswegen stellen
wir uns dieser aufgaben sagen ja wir
brauchen als wir brauchen es und wir
wollen es dieses größte erneuerbare
energien programm aller zeiten ihnen
reicht das interessanterweise mich habe
ich gelesen na ja wir unterstützen
ehrgeizige ziele und wir glauben wenn
man ehrgeizige ziele hat dann muss man
alle potenziale mitnehmen und wir
erleben bei der ampel das ist also eine
klassengesellschaft der öko energien
gibt da steht sehr wind und sonne im
mittelpunkt es werden dort auch
potenziale vergeben immer noch nicht die
klare botschaft steuerfreiheit für das
private photovoltaik dach haben wir
gefordert lehnt die ampel ab und dann
werden aber die potenziale von
geothermie von biomasse in der kleinen
wasserkraft nicht in der weise wie es
nötig wäre unterstützt bei der kleinen
wasserkraft unter dem eindruck unter
unserer kritik wird es nachgebessert die
angekündigten kürzungen nehmen sie
zurück das ist richtig aber bei der
biomasse an dem tag muss man sich
vergegenwärtigen an dem tag wo die ampel
die co2 intensive kohlekraft
wiederbelebt wird die biomasse weiter
gedeckelt wird der einsatz von biomethan
bei
kraft-wärme-kopplung gedrosselt es kann
doch nicht sein dass man das co2
intensive wiederbelebt und die grüne
bioenergie weiter deckelt die potenziale
nicht nutzen müssen doch gerade in der
jetzigen situation tun
ich greife jetzt vielleicht in der kürze
der zeit nur einen der punkte aus sie
haben gerade gesagt wir würden ablehnen
das bis 30 kwp photovoltaik steuerfrei
gestellt ist wir haben in unserem
entschließungsantrag klargemacht dass
das das nächst ist was wir tun was immer
darauf hingewiesen wie viele gesetze und
verordnungen wir gerade gleichzeitig
anpacken und man muss ein stück weit
portionieren damit die arbeit auch gut
ist ja da noch qualität drin ist und
deswegen haben wir diese steuerrecht
nicht auch noch gleichzeitig aufgemacht
das muss das finanzministerium
vorbereiten wir haben es aber auch schon
gemeinsam geeint und vereinbart dass das
unsere zeitung unsere zeit ist leider
fast schon oben eigentlich immer ein
gutes zeichen wenn man wenn man das
gefühl hat ups schon vorbei die
viertelstunde aber abschließend
vielleicht noch mal und auch ganz kurz
wie heizen sie und welche maßnahmen
haben sie ergriffen für den herbst also
wir haben kunden einer genossenschaft
sehr sehr guten dämmstandard so dass die
heizkörper eigentlich auch im winter
meistens kein satz und sehr jung wir
leben in einer mietwohnung im dort eine
gasheizung legen schon grundsätzlich
wird damit wert darauf damit sparsam
umzugehen und jetzt in der jetzigen
situation noch mehr meine gastherme ist
vor zwei wochen gewartet worden ich bin
jetzt guter dinge für den herbst und
hoffe mal dass die nachzahlung nicht so
dramatisch wird wie viele vorhergesagt
haben vielen vielen dank herr jungen
dass sie heute morgen bei uns gewesen
sind debatte um 9 wird sicherlich
spannend werden und wahrscheinlich auch
ein bisschen lebendig wenn man sich
angeguckt hat wie gestern schon war in
der aktuellen stunde zu dem thema vielen
dank ihnen beiden für heute morgen und
sie dürfen jetzt auch reingehen